صحيح عثمان يمكن القول انهدنا تسير ولكن
ليس في كل مواقع هناك تركيز على منطقه
صغيره هي منطقه القصر الجمهوري وهذه
العمليات ما زالت مستمره في محيط المطر
تابعوا معنا شكرا
الهدنه ان صح التعبير لا نستطيع نقول انها
تترنح في السودان ولا نستطيع نقول بانها
ثابته بشكل كبير مع ما قاله مراسلون بان
المناطق الرئيسيه للقتال هي بطبيعه الحال
الخرطوم صحيح ولكن هناك هدوء واضح في
منطقه خرطوم بحري واندرمان مع طلعات جويه
وفق ما اعلنت الدعم السريع لطيران الجيش
في خرطوم بحري وام درمان ولكن لم تشهد لم
يشهد اليوم الحادي عشر من المعارك لم يشهد
عمليات عسكريه واضحه في خرطوم بحري وام
درمان ليكون الهدوء الحذر هو سيد الموقف
في هاتين المنطقتين مدينتي خرطوم بحري وام
درمان وطبعا الخرطوم التي تشكل جميعها
الخرطوم او الكبرى او العاصمه الخرطوم
العمليات العسكريه تركز فيها المنطقه
الجنوبيه من من نهر النيل الازرق هذا هو
المستطيل او المربع الذي تتركز فيه
العمليات العسكريه خلال الساعات القليله
الماضيه مع اعلانات متكرره بين الجانبين
الجيش والدعم السريع عن خروقات كما وصفوها
واتهامات متبادله لخرق الهدنه الجاريه
حاليا هذه المنطقه اذا ما دخلنا في
خريطتها اكثر فنحن نلاحظ وجود هذه المواقع
الحساسه طبعا على الشاشه الان صور مباشره
من الخرطوم ونشاهد اعمده الدخان وبعض
المناطق الهادئه نسبيا ولكن المناطق التي
نتحدث عنها على الخريطه هي المناطق التي
شهدت العمليات العسكريه الاهم مع تمركز
قوات الدعم السريع في اكثر من منطقه مهمه
وهي المنطقه الشماليه الشرقيه من المطار
هذا هو مطار الخرطوم الدولي كما نشاهد
على هذا الخط هنا تتمركز قوات الدعم
السريع في بعض الاحياء في المنطقه
الشماليه الشرقيه من المطار وايضا تتمركز
قوات الدعم السريع في حي اسمه حي المطار
وهو الذي يضم ترقيه الجيش او مقر القياده
العامه للقوات المسلحه السودانيه تتمركز
هنا في هاتان النقطتان وفي هاتين النقطتين
عفوا قوات الدعم السريع بالاضافه الى
تمركزها ايضا في محيط القصر الجمهوري لذلك
نسمع بين الحين والاخر
باشتباكات عنيفه بين القوات بين الجيش
السوداني في محيط المطار وفي محيط القصر
الجمهوري لوجود قوات الدعم السريع في هذه
المنطقه اذا تحدثنا عن هذه المنطقه فنحن
نتحدث عن حوالي
كيلو ونصف تقريبا
اقل من اثنين كيلو متر المسافه بين النهر
النيل الازرق المنطقه الشماليه وصولا الى
المطار وهذه المنطقه شارع
هذا الشارع الذي هذه الجسور التي تربط بين
خرطوم وخرطوم بحري على نهر الازرق تم طبعا
حركه السير متوقفه فيها بطبيعه الحال ولكن
هذا هو المربع الذي اشرنا له والذي يشهد
العمليات العسكريه لانه يضم القصر
الجمهوري ونحن نتحدث تقريبا عن حركه
تقريبا خمسه كيلو مترات بهذا الاتجاه
وكيلو ونصف او اثنين كيلو بهذا الاتجاه
وبالتالي نستطيع القول انها مساحه صغيره
جدا التي تكون فيها العمليات العسكريه على
اشدها طبعا مراسله محمد الطيب كان في
منطقه السوق المركزي في هذه في هذه
المنطقه المنطقه الجنوبيه محيط المدينه
الرياضيه تشهد هذه المنطقه بحسب محمد
الطيب مراسلنا من هناك هدوءا حذرا
وانتعاشا بسيطا او عوده للحركه حركه
الاسواق حتى هذه اللح مع هدوء العمليات
العسكريه في هذه المنطقه مع تقدم القوات
الجيش بحسب ما تقول لانها كانت خلال
الايام القليله الماضيه تجري عمليات تمشيط
في المنطقه الجنوبيه ليتمركز القتال وفقا
ما ذكرنا في هذه المنطقه بقي ان اشير بان
القوات الجيش اتهمت قوات الدعم السريع
بانها تستجلب قوات من الجهه الغربيه وفق
ما اعلن الجيش بان الدعم السريع يجلب
قواته من الجهه الغربيه ونحن نعلم ان ايضا
الدعم السريع كان له معسكرات مهمه في
المنطقه الغربيه من البلاد وتحديدا دارفور
ومحيط دارفور وكانت قبل ايام القوات
المسلحه او الجيش السوداني قال بان هناك
عمليات عدم استقرار في المنطقه الغربيه من
الابيض عدم الاستقرار في هذه المنطقه وفق
الجيش بطبيعه الحال ناتج عن استدعاء الدعم
السريع لقوات من لدعم او تعزيزات عسكريه
للدعم السريع من الجهه الغربيه باتجاه
العاصمه الخرطوم لتكون العاصمه الخرطوم هي
محور العمليات خلال الساعات القليله
الماضيه مع هدوء حذر في احياء خرطوم بحري
وام درمان واشتداد المعارك في المنطقه
الوسطى من مدينه الخرطوم العاصمه او محيط
القصر الجمهوري ومطار الخرطوم الدولي هذه
المعلومات بطبيعه الحال بحاجه الى مزيد من
التفاصيل والتحليل ستكون مع عثمان ومريم